the Trump administration says it's still
separating a small number of immigrant
children from adults that happens when
parental relationships cannot be
confirmed or if the adult appears to
threaten the child's safety
Mireya Villarreal spoke to a Mexican
woman who says that her granddaughter
was taken away even though she is her
legal guardian she's near the border in
Tornillo Texas with that family story
Mireya good morning well good morning we
met on halika and her three-year-old
granddaughter last week when they were
getting ready to cross into the u.s. and
ask for asylum on halika told me that
she was worried about being separated
from Sophia even though she's the only
mother that that three-year-old has ever
known on Friday her worst fear came true
namitha he's gone Sophia was pleading
with her not to leave her alone not to
let her go not to leave her with the
police
unhealthy guy told us she does not know
where her three-year-old granddaughter
Sophia is ever since they were separated
by immigration officials Friday these
are papers that say that you are the
legal guardian and they said that these
don't matter okay no no these aren't
important Ruben Garcia is helping on
halika and other separated families he
runs the annunciation house in El Paso
which provides shelter and legal
assistance to immigrants on Sunday
Annunciation House took in 32 immigrant
parents after federal authorities
withdrew criminal charges for illegal
entry the parents were separated from
their children and do not know where
they are when this policy was
implemented in the beginning it was
implemented without any plan the
Department of Homeland Security says
there is a process to ensure family
members know the location of their
children there is a 1-800 number and an
email providing information Homeland
Security also says the reunification
process is well coordinated but Garcia
says it's not the system is set up that
once you take the child from the parent
the parent then is presumed to
potentially not be adequate to regain
their child unhealthy guy says
immigration officials told her it'll be
days before she gets any information on
Sophia's whereabouts what is the hardest
part of all of this
in NASA parathion but I mean the hardest
part is being away from her separated
both battling malapit on the official
told her that she would be in a place
that was safe and secure but I'm meeting
and there is nothing like being with
family on helices case right now is
still pending in immigration court Rubin
says the immigrants that are at
Annunciation house right now are not
finding that 1-800 number to be helpful
and it is still unclear if parents that
are in detention right now have access
to email or the ability to call that
what 800 number
bianna so many unintended consequences
here we hope that the search for Sofia
ends well Maria thank you